That's what I'm saying. >> I need to I need to have a little
girl to wrap myself around. >> Oh, that's what they're
referring to is is these old streams. And she goes, "That's not
true. Like, I' I've never said anything like that." And it's
like, "Bro, it's all on tape. It's literally all on tape. Everything
you've said from before is on tape." >> Oh, I guess you
>> I need to have like a 12-year-old. >> This is
what I think this is what Trump meant when Trump talked about
like winning so much. You're going to get tired of winning. YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY, "PLEASE STOP. PLEASE STOP WINNING. PLEASE, I WANT
TO STOP WINNING. Please stop letting them win. Please stop winning.
It's too much. Too much winning. That's what this is right now.
It's just too much winning.
>> Anyway, let's listen to the Hassan clip >> I forget
what they're called. I think No, it wasn't Loner Box. Loner Box
didn't work. Uh Hutch didn't work. They tried to like promote
Hutch a lot. They tried to promote Loner Box a lot and it didn't
work. And I think um the name was what? Food shops. Uh you left
out details. She is an admitted Oh, yeah. I forgot. Um, there's
also that as well. Apparently, this person got outed as a
>> Why did Assan
sometimes when he does drama, he's like, "If I just pretend to
be an android, nobody can accuse me of really liking drama."
Oh, yeah. I forgot that is also true. That she is like also
bro, just have some emotions. Speak like a human being. Okay,
it's fine. Oh, yeah. I forgot that also that she is also a >> Wait,
dude. Can you can you stop with the pantheon? Come on, man. I
think the name was what? Food shops. Uh, you left out details.
She is an admitted Oh, yeah. I forgot. Um, there's also that
as well. Apparently, this person >> It is funny. Yeah,
it is. >> Outed as a Yeah. So, it didn't really work. It
didn't really work. It didn't uh work at all. She self admitted.
Well, it turns out I there are ops that I don't even know exist
out there, but one thing is a guarantee. They are going to be
criminals in some variety, some way, shape, or form. Um, this
is like the the primary driving force. >> I do like the
person that edited this. I do like that they didn't do the um
they didn't add as gold to this, okay? Cuz asmin gold's really
not a part of this, actually. If you add asmin gold, I feel like
you're operating in not good faith. Asmin Gold, that's the one
thing you got to always leave Asmin Gold alone on is he ain't
touching people, okay? He ain't doing that. He ain't doing that.
That guy is in committed relationships or nothing. Committed
relationships to either his stream or another person.
So, I I will give him that every single time. Thank God he's
not, you know, somebody violating consent consistently, somebody
getting in trouble >> behind almost all of my ops. You
know, there's a if you exist for a long enough timeline and you're
an op of mine, you end up getting into trouble in this way somehow.
I don't know why, but in any case, I forget what they're called.
I think No, it wasn't Loner Box. Loner Box didn't work. Uh, Hutch
didn't Oh, we're restarting. We're restarting. Okay, so Food
Chops doesn't like this clip. Goes and makes a post. Okay, >> Hey,
I'm pretty sure this is against Twitch to leverage transphobic
insults at me. Clearly Hassan is transphobic and he is no ally
to the trans people in any way. Now this with food shop's background
like this I I truly believe when dead domain like hates this
person I I know dead domain got mixed up in this as well. When
Dead Domain hates this person, if you're a trans person and you
see somebody who's like openly said the things that food shops
has said and then they go, "Oh, it's transphobic to call me a
that's got to be that's got to drive you insane, right? That
somebody who has literally talked about this stuff that they
would go and try to use your identity as a shield that they would
be, you know, they'd make the statements they did and then they
try to throw up the transphobia shield, the shield that you have,
right? that I got to imagine that drives you insane. Like I I
would imagine even people in the DG sphere would look at this
and go like that's insane for you to do to try to like as a a
vowed
child attracted person. Okay, I'm I I feel like was appropriate,
but as somebody who's had legitimate like attraction to children
like food shops has,
for her to throw this up as a shield is just super goofy to me,
man. It's crazy.
Okay, she continues, but wait one second. There was the This
is where we had to mix in the Deeperama tweet.
You're transgender.
What? What? Huh?
Huh?
What? What? What? No. No. I didn't know. I did. I didn't know.
I didn't know.
Okay. Oh my goodness.
Anyway, a little bit more. Hey,
This is dangerous to my life. This is dangerous to my life. Keep
Twitch a safe platform or sorry, keeping Twitch a safe platform
should be your highest priority. I've been doxed before, too,
so his rabbid audience could go after me for this, too.
That's Dude, I
I like they obviously
they had to have known that doing this would mean all of these
clips, all of this stuff getting dredged up again, it all getting
litigated again. I know they don't like it being litigated or
they say they don't. They refer to themselves as a pedal on multiple
occasions. It's okay to say it. Yeah, sure, sure, sure, sure.
Okay. Uh, note tagging in at Twitch 2 just in case these don't
reach these people. That is editors like Austinox has put Cobbertate,
Dr. Disrespect, and as comparable examples to me. Insane.
Well, in that you have some sort of predation scandal. Yeah.
Yeah, that that's the connection there. Obviously, he basically
calls me a criminal, which is additionally insane considering
how I haven't been charged, arrested, or had any contact with
the FBI or police in any way whatsoever. I would like to see
proof of this. What does he say precisely? >> Know exists
out there, but one thing is a guaranteed
criminals in some variety, some way, shape, or form. Um, this
is like the the primary driving. >> Okay, sure. Criminals
probably the wrong word to use, right? Predators. Um,
pasts easier to use. Sure. Going to be going to be. Sure. Sure.
All Dr. Disrespect did was message a 17-year-old. Didn't she
technically do the same thing? Uh, she did technically do the
same thing. Although, I will say Dr. Disrespect, I believe, just
knew how old the person was and was like, "Let's let's go."
Kind of a move to be honest with you.
So, Lib responds, "You're openly trans and admitted to being
attracted to children and consuming drawn pornographic material
of children. Trying to hide behind the trans community while
actively harming trans people in that way really shows how selfish
you are." Yeah, that's a very good comment. Obviously true, right?
Yeah. No, I know. I'm I know I'm talking about Hassan's coverage.
Yeah. Yeah. Um using ID pole liberalism to defend is nasty work.
Lauo
>> calling it the resi clip. Which one is the resi clip?
I forget. A lot of them are resi clips.
Is this the one where
No, this isn't the one where she talks about wanting a 13-year-old
wrapped around her. >> I'm only into the most feminine
of the most feminine. >> That's what I'm saying. >> I
need to I need to have a little girl to wrap myself around. >> Oh,
no. It is that one. H.
>> Oh, like your like big spoon is what you're saying.
Oh, I get [__] >> I need to have like a 12-year-old
Thank you for
going further. What is with these people that like
I feel like this is inherent in a whole bunch of um of like attention-seeking
degenerates online where where they like they will say something
to be offensive, but that won't be offensive enough. Was that
food shops? Yeah, that was food chops.
It's like bro, we all got how it was already gross. We were already
grossed out and then you had to make it like more explicit.
Even more explicit. >> What? That's >> Dude, just
the silence. Way to way to kill the conversation, man. Way to
keep the conversation.
Uh here is here is evidence of self-admitted food shops declaring
that she needs a 12-year-old to wrap herself around. I think
that's actually an important part of the quote. There are also
in other instances where she she said she crosses the street
when kids are around terrified of what she might do and calls
herself a lowercase peep.
This is true. This is actually entirely true. Yep. Oh, here's
a trans person who's going to get very very very angry. Okay.
I'm just I would imagine trans people everywhere would get super
mad about this. Okay. It's it's rough to watch all the clips,
which by the way, I still have all of that stuff. We could still
go through a whole bunch of that just in case people are a little
not caught up or anything. Uh do dead domain quote tweets. Is
this the ape gamer tweet? No, it's food chops. Okay, so here's
another tweet right here. Here's you admitting on camera to being
attracted to children. I unironically consume lolly. It's just
a part of me. It's not like I can change my attractions. This
is food drop saying this. How [__] dare you try to
weaponize this ID pole [__] of being an oo trans
woman to deflect absolute scum. Yeah, that that would be about
my that's like if I were a part of that identity group, I feel
like this would be my reaction.
Like
let's say hypothetically, and this is purely hypothetical. I
do not believe this applies to reality, but hypothetically, let's
say food shops is not a okay, I I know we're straining the the
bounds of credul here. I know we're straining to imagine such
a world, but imagine that she wasn't a
then she would still in this world, this hypothetical world that
basically almost certainly doesn't exist.
She would still be somebody who performs like their online for
clicks and views and then actually tries to go and use the trans
identity as a shield against getting called out for that.
Right? That's the best case scenario here is she is somebody
who is consistently used being a as a way to get clicks, being
a as a way to get clicks, trying to defend those things, trying
to debate those things, and then she tries to use the trans identity
as a shield. Like even in the world where she was just doing
that as a way to perform and gain attention, even negative attention,
even in that world, she's still an awful person for doing this,
right? So, >> but while I was like actually covering the
topic itself,
>> I need to say PD because I don't think YouTube likes
it. I don't think YouTube likes it when I say say that. Okay,
it's fake background. I got you. Yeah, I figured it out. So,
obviously because of that, right? And then I also admitted at
some point that I unironically consume. So, if you don't like
the fact that I
you're free to leave. Okay.
um you know it like that is just a part of me you know like it's
it's not like I can change my attractions or anything like that
right but I don't think I'm a I really don't think so um I'm
just going to say even that statement there at the end
that's like a really baffling thing to say to me that's like
that that's actually crazy isn't it
uh I don't I don't think I'm uh I don't think I'm a
what this is a month ago yeah this is her defending like a month
ago her defending the uh defending against like I think mutin
and Dan during all of that
So like when she says it's all old stuff, this was a month ago.
Yeah, this is when she this is around the time where she said
she was happy that Dan's family was getting swatted and doxed,
right? This is around that time.
>> Anyway, that's the end of that clip.
What are the replies like to this? Because I do think this is
totally fine. Uh Destiny uh all my browser windows. Are we good
on the stream? We are. Okay. Okay. Destiny Orbiter 2, if you
can believe such a thing. Weird how it's always the exact people
you expect. Oh, and keep my name out of your mouth at not food
shops. Crawl back under whatever rock you used out from under.
Trans people do not need you making us all look worse.
Why? Dead domains destiny video is dog.
Wow. You are only a single step away from something like this
happening to you by Hassan. You think they'll be okay with your
internet and dark internet and darkstalkers?
With your internet and darkstalkers if you dare disagree with
them. Nope. Enjoy the bed you have made.
actually calling out this uh I hope you know that you're making
your own bed by calling this person out. I hope you know that
the only person who likes trans people on the entire internet
is Destiny. Who else has had multiple threesomes with trans people
other than Destiny? He's the only advocate you have, guys. He's
the only advocate. Okay. If you've hit a growth wall, no press
is bad press might be real. I don't think so. Evil even less.
I This This is always bad press. This is something that causes
nobody serious to want to interact with you. This is something
that like all of this pedto it's this is the maybe one of two
or three things on the entire internet. I'm I can't even think
of the others. I'm just saying for argument that there might
be where like people will totally opt out of talking to you forever
over it. Like it's just over if you try to do this stuff.
If you if you like try to defend this stuff, if you are consistently
saying you feel these attractions, I think it's just over for
you unironically. Okay.
What is this? What is this? What is this?
Oh, wait. Is this
This is the
17-year-old. Yeah. Okay. This is the 17-year-old Food Shops was
interacting with. Now, I think food shops didn't know they were
17.
Last I saw, food shops didn't know they were 17. And then once
this person told them they were 17, food jobs stopped interacting,
I think. I think. Okay,
that's my understanding of this the last time. So, this disgusting
weirdo dated me when I was 17, by the way, and would call my
body a body and admitted to screenshotting pics of my appearance
without my consent. And how it's too late. I'm so glad I barely
showed any parts of me to her. I distinctly recall them having
streams and where they were talking about how they had PCD or
OCD and would have to consume because it is a it was a medical
necessity prescribed by their doctor and she would talk to me
about how I just watched that stuff and it's just like a meme
and then I saw the being discussed and it was like hours of her
explaining how she must consume and how she's making diagrams
in MS Paint about this. This is all correct though. This part
is all correct.
Um, I mean, all of this is, it sounds like all of this is correct.
I'm just saying I think food chops did stop interacting with
them when she found out that this person was 17.
Also, I will throw out another thing that I probably shouldn't,
but I'm I'm infinitely good faith in a way nobody else is. Okay,
I'm actually the No, I'm not going to do the whole bit where
I'm like, I'm the actually the best faith person. I'm going to
I'm going to help. I do think also this person I think is like
a known honey potter. like they intentionally while they were
a minor were trying to message people. Um and
now I think this this person messaged me I think about was it
I can't remember what it was about. It was about something. This
person messaged me on my own on my old account and somebody saw
that they had messaged me or heard that they had messaged me
like let me know they were a honey potter or something. Um it
was about stream content or something. They like asked a question
about stream content like something I was covering on stream
and I answered and they didn't interact anymore. Thank god.
But I'm just saying I I've heard that they're a known honey potter,
too.
Okay. Some of these combos are one-sided because a bunch of deleted
messages. Others are one-sided, like me being text heavy and
her not responding seemingly cuz we were calling. But these are
like some examples. I get aggroed when she appears on my timeline
cuz she is like cuz like she is so dishonest.
No. Wait. How do you stand to watch so many commentators when
all they do is make fun of degenerate owners? They are targeting
you. To be fair, they're gooners, too. Lyrics. Well, yeah. Chud
talks about every 5 seconds. Lol. Haha.
I can't believe this cute IRL Japanese girl is in the space who
is actually into me. This is why I think I'm being catfished.
Well, kind of. The chance the chances can't be possible. Well,
let's see. No evidence of your identity or existence, but that's
okay. I guess the pictures could be AI generated. Hm. As what
is an IRL Japanese girl? Cute IRL Japanese girl. Cute IRL. Japanese
girl. What is an IRL? It's almost like that is a child. An actual
child. Hold on a second. Let me see. Yeah, this person is on
my friends list. Hold on. Let me see what my messages are with
them. Oh god. Thank god. This is This is what it was about. Okay.
I've been I've been messaged by this person before. They're on
my friends list. There's our entire message history.
Oh, hold on. I'll show that. There's no like scroll bar or anything.
Boom. That's it. That's it.
No. I listen, I think this person,
if I've if I've ever heard anything about this person is that
they try to intentionally like honeypot people. Also, 2025, they
might have been an adult at this point, too. I think they were
18 at this point. If they were 17 back here in these food shops
DMs,
you're probably
18 here.
No, I just I listen, I don't want to be accused of anything,
man. I'm very I'm very militant about this stuff. Okay.
Very militant.
You're implying you would fall for a honeypot. No, I'm not. No,
I'm not. I would never have a conversation with this person ever.
I just wouldn't do it, man. Wouldn't do it, man. Not worth it.
Yeah. I said I openly consume Continue on with the food shop
stuff. Openly consumed on a stream one time and everybody freaked
out. It was not just one time. In fact, you did it after this.
You did it after this. A month ago. A year later from this. More
than a year later from this. Okay, good. Make that clear. Well,
I I think it is clear, but okay. And everybody freaked out. Yes.
Yeah. What? There's an entire stream where I admit to that. And
everybody was like, "Food shops, you're a" And I'm like, "No,
I'm into that body type, but I'm not into kids. I'm into petite."
Actually, she does talk about how the like teacher student dynamic
gets her off specifically like the power dynamic that she likes
these smaller innocent people because of the power dynamic. She's
talked about that as
makes me sad when it's an actual child because something feels
about it feels off. Yeah, exactly. I feel gross an actual kid,
but I'm into super petite like small and small.
So that's why when I say when you say I'm flat as a board, I'm
like what's the issue? Haha. One time this one Twitter account
was so into me. Another girl.
Okay. And this is the very cool drawing she did. Very cool drawing.
Very very very cool drawing. She says on her stream now that
she's into girls that are early to mid20s. It's always retelling
the story. Yeah. Well, she's she's basically totally rewriting
the previous story. So, everybody talks about like these old
streams that she had, right? Everybody talks about these.
And
that's what they're referring to is is these old streams. And
she goes, "That's not true. Like, I've I've never said anything
like that." It's like, "Bro, it's all on tape. It's literally
all on tape. Everything you've said from before is on tape."
By the way, the most concerning part about food shops is that
she said, "I have this PCD thing, this OCD." And I went to a
psychologist and they told me, "You have to off."
OCD, I believe, is actually a thing, but a psychologist, a psychiatrist
would never psych psychologist, psychiatrist, nobody, no medical
professional would ever say, "You actually need to off to this
stuff to treat that." That's not how you do it, right? like they
have an like an obsessive thing where they're concerned about
being considered a or something
and she says, "Oh, well, you have to off." Nobody would ever
prescribe that to you, right? Because there's no solid science
saying that this does or does not that it increases or decreases
your likelihood to act on something in real life. Nobody would
ever do this because it is not medically like proven to do anything.
And it sounds and if you get brought in front of like a malpractice
board, you are going to get your license taken away. If you recommended
this to somebody and they touched a kid after that, you would
be totally for life. No psychologist, no psychiatrist would ever
recommend this. It's totally insane. So there could be some kind
of exposure. Well, that's what they're referring to, evil Johnny
Bravo. But their proof for this is basically saying they mentioned
OCD to a psychologist one time and showing an email, but it's
not POCD specifically.
So, what I think it is is she heard about exposure therapy from
somebody. She self-prescribed exposure therapy in this way and
then tried to say her doctor told her to do it. It's obviously
not true.
>> I will just be your pay.
>> Hello. Reuben donated $3. The doctor offered her a lollipop
and she heard pop
>> gross. Okay.
So then we have food shops responding to some of these tweets
throughout the day. Give me a second.
Give me a second.
Give me a second. Give me a second. Okay, so here's one of the
the responses. You are a and there's clips of you admitting this.
Lol. Pathetic creep. No FBI raid, no police raid, no charges,
no arrest to this day. Uh do we think that's the bar for calling
somebody a What? Why would you have to be arrested after you've
admitted to this attraction? And after you've admitted you cross
the street when kids are walking near you, after you've aditted
admitted all of the things you have, why would we need an arrest?
I don't understand.
This is like tee logic, right? It's completely techone logic.
It's like without a without a criminal charge, you actually can't
accuse me of anything. You can't say anything bad about me without
a criminal charge. It's like, okay, I don't I don't think that's
true. Pretty sure.
Amazing. The progressive left. The progressive far-left shows
their true colors of being an anti-Semitic, transphobic, hate
mob. Transphobic. Anti-Semitic. Huh?
What? I haven't even been approached by the FBI. Nobody knows
that I'm a guys. Nobody's made a criminal complaint against me.
She's complaining and child abuser. What's really funny, Missy
Elliot, is that Yes. And I'm pretty sure a lot of her obsession
with the stuff came from her watching Mr. Girl content. And Mr.
Girl would make a strong distinction between these things, right?
Like Max would make a very strong distinction between somebody
who's a child abuser and somebody's a who has that attraction
and refuses to act on it. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. She does know
better. Yes. Yep. Precisely.
It's very funny. People start forgetting this stuff very quickly.
I think it's funny cuz she also makes techone content and that
she's basically trying to adopt the techone tactics is super
funny to me. Okay.
Super super funny.
Okay. We keep going.
So, this person comes along.
Somebody's replying here. Food shop's going to reply to this
person, I believe. This person says, uh, quotes, "I need to have
a little girl to wrap around to wrap myself around." Well, that's
a pedto. And Food Chops responds, "Oh, no, an edgy joke. I'm
sure Hassan doesn't have a ton of these examples. Look in the
mirror, bud. Hassan is probably more of a than I am."
No, I don't think that's true. No, I don't think that's true.
I don't think that's true, man. I think that's that's not true
at all. These were very serious conversations, by the way. These
were very, very, very serious conversations where she was saying
these things and she could say some of the things were jokes.
Some of them, like this one, I don't think was I don't think
this was a joke, man.
Lots of this stuff isn't a joke that she's talking about. She's
trying to roll some irony into it, but it's not working. Okay,
it's not working. Any guesses on the type of persons that thinks
the punchlines about children are normal, edgy jokes? because
if I joked about that at work, I'd get knocked the out. Lau,
it's by the way find pedo jokes funny.
Well, I would say that that's not necessarily true. Uh the thing
we've discussed over and over again is like um this is true for
Destiny, it's true for food shops. These people aren't funny
enough. There is a funny enough joke that you could make like
a joke land. I believe that fully. You could make a joke about
yourself being a and it could land and be funny. But the problem
is there are certain kinds of people who will consistently make
those jokes when they're not funny. When they're just low tier
jokes, right? And they're not funny at all. And I think those
people I'm I'm side eyeing. Okay,
that's that's who I'm side eyeing. If you're consistently making
those jokes, it's a little weird. Okay, this is it gets odd.
She's just like Hutch. Wait, what is this? And a S for the destiny.
I would rather vote for a Democrat to defeat the current fascist
party in power. Can you say the same?
Oh no, she's Hutchfield. Oh no, she's a big Hutch fan. Oh no.
Oh no.
Like, does she understand the optics of this that people are
basically going to like you talk about people who your coalition
over? Okay, you talk about people who [__] your coalition
over.
Republicans say constantly that Democrats are trying to like
sweep into the party.
Right. They say it constantly. This is like almost as big as
the trans thing. This is like objectively doing that.
This is objectively like trying to make this like sort of okay
and a joke and something, you know, we're fine with these people.
Like you are performing the function of like Republican useful
idiot here.
Luckily, probably nobody knows about it. But if they did know
about it, man,
it'd probably be a problem. What do we have next? This is the
gatafumodor reply. Using IPL liberalism to defend Nasty work.
Hassan existing breaks brain so hard they're purposely drawing
everyone's attention to their own ped to try to own him. Like
what in the world? Yeah,
this is this is a good reply right here.
Like
this actually Hana's bad brain rot causing you to inform the
entire internet that you're actually a I
wild man. It's It's just I
crazy work. It's just crazy work, dude. Boot chops response.
Wait, did she respond to Gatufumador?
She did. As opposed to ID pole leftism. Jesus Christ, man.
Waddle waddle me. kick.com/jstk.
It's where the kickstream is at. Um, okay.
I to as opposed to ID pole leftism. I the the whole thing I you
don't need liberalism or leftism is in this using ID pole to
defend is nasty work. I don't think it matters if it's liberalism
or
This doesn't matter. This is like a total bait word.
Yeah, both would be bad.
If you're if you're trying to use your identity as a shield against
your prior statements of you're lumping in people who have your
exact identity into that like thing and you're basically saying
we shouldn't consider anybody who says these things a but we
should and you shouldn't use transness as a shield for that obviously.
So, okay. All right. Ellie B arguing the replies. What? Oh, Ellie
B is going deep in the replies. Okay. So, she does this first
one. You're openly trans and admitted to being attracted to children.
All this. Yeah. I don't know why they deny it despite admitting
it. Following the Destiny playbook. What?
Is this confusing? That Destiny admitted to the things he did
and then started attacking people for it? That's not That's not
super confusing to me. Deny the thing you've already admitted
to and hope nobody notices. Claim you're being targeted based
on your immutable characteristics. Attack anyone who calls you
on your [__] It won't work for food shops, but it's
funny to see her try. Yeah, LB's winning. What does Destiny deny
that he did in fact do? Non-cons consensually distributing porn
to five women at last count. Sure.
I mean, I don't think he denies this happened. Yes, he does.
Uh, it's kind of funny and ironic that Pixie doing exactly literally
exactly what Just Bley Think said she would. Lol W. What is this?
Told Pixie on her show, you're going to fake me to someone. Like
I'm pretty sure just pearly things literally rolled.
Literally told her. Oh, am I going backwards? I'm going backwards.
The heart five. It's just the same because she literally played
into the absolute insane perfect red pill nightmare stereotype
in every single way. Like I'm pretty sure like this this is crazy.
Sorry, I I was reading it backwards at first. I'm pretty sure
just Pearly Things literally told her told Pixie on her show,
you're going to fake me to someone. That's bruh. This is the
funny thing is DJers think this is true. They're like, "Oh, yeah.
All this was made up." It wasn't,
by the way.
Oh, I I'm so getting baited back into talking about this. Me,
man. I don't want to talk about this. But the entire the entire
idea of the implied consent that allowed him to share it was
like, "Oh, well, we could share it with trusted partners." You
shared it to a dude who you didn't whose identity you didn't
even verify to any real extent, who you'd known for a week. That's
who you shared it to.
That's like every part of that implied consent argument falls
apart when you find out that Destiny shared it a week after meeting
the person,
Like it's just totally insane. It's totally insane that we've
made it anywhere down the line on this where he could pretend
that this didn't all happen and it's not all documented. It's
it's so wild that everybody just goes, "Well, actually, you have
to go to court to figure out what really happened here." No,
you don't. No, you don't. No, you don't. No, you don't. No, you
don't. No, you don't. No, you don't. No, you don't. No, you don't.
No, you don't. This isn't him denying that he gave a video to
Rose. This is him saying that Pixie is going after him like for
like revenge allegations when he never had engaged in revenge,
but he's not getting gone after for revenge allegations. This
is you being a and not reading the documents, right? They don't
allege revenge in the documents. That's not what they allege.
Yes. Easy. Ellie B totally winning the whole time. LB obviously
winning.
So, which is something he's mentioned before. So, she's suing
him for non-consensually distributing her videos. He admitted
to non-consensually distributing her videos. He now claims, depending
on the day, that she implicitly consented or that she explicitly
told him not to or or that she explicitly told him not to spread
the videos around despite admitting to the contrary. Do you do
you deny that in all of the cases of revenge Pixie has used in
her case, the defendant usually is using the to attack the character
or humiliate the woman? Here's the statute. I know you trust
Destiny a lot, but you shouldn't let him do this. He's cherrypicking
an irrelevant detail to deflect from the substance. He does it
a lot when he refuts the case law cited.
Yeah, I don't know why that would matter. It's like this is the
law. My point is that we are judging and focusing on him for
the wrong for a wrong that is to me is the same as a per like
if a person stole a keychain from a gas station when there's
a person responsible for like robbery and murder in that same
gas station.
Dude, all right. H,
this person's just wrong. This person would never like talk to
LB anywhere
either, which is kind of goofy, right? It's like you arguing
that because somebody robbed and murdered in that gas station,
you shouldn't be charged for stealing the keychain. You could
argue the scale is different, right? Patry,
they're just living up to their name. They kind of are, aren't
they? And by the way, but for this keychain being stolen, it's
like you stole this keychain or something
and then something happens because you did that, right? Like,
but for Destiny doing the initial act that is not quite as bad
as um it's obviously not as bad as Solo leaking all the videos
to the internet, right? But for Destiny doing the act of sending
it to somebody he'd known for a week, Pixie's video would never
be out there.
It's pretty easy to understand, right? Uh is Ellie B a personality
that talks outside of Twitter? I think she went on like Wick
panels at some point. I think
you really think that having intimate material of yourself and
your body sent around to random people on the internet by the
person you trusted enough to share yourself in the most vulnerable
way possible with is equivalent to stealing a keychain from a
gas station. That is also a thing you're sort of minimizing the
thing. It would make me stressed if anything it wouldn't be traumatizing
like salt or though why what is this relevant to
for a lot of women? This is a huge violation. I mean I'm sure
it is but it's probably a matter of skill too. If I was having
sex with Destiny and my nudes got leaked, I'd probably be very
anxious. And with a mental state I'm in now, it would be it would
be bad. I think I I think I could understand the feelings, but
there's more to it. It's not nudes. That's downplay. It's a video
of a second act. Sure. To me, it's roughly the same thing. No,
it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. I don't know
why one is much worse than any than the other. Either way, your
body is displayed in a sexual manner with someone. There's a
difference between a picture of your body and a video of you
performing a sex act. both are vulnerable, but one is a lot more
vulnerable than the other. Maybe it depends on how you feel about
sex. I mean, it's also the fact that like and Destiny
later becomes aware of this, right? That Pixie didn't want any
of that out there that she didn't feel and Destiny didn't feel
at the time that Pixie having sex with anybody like moved her
up the ladder. Although, now Destiny argues the opposite that
she was trying to her way up like a streamer ladder of some kind,
which I don't know, maybe he's got evidence for that or something,
right?
And this is Yes. All to go past the point of Destiny arguing
that he did violate her consent in the worst way possible. Her
trust in the worst way possible. Sorry.
Anyway, why did I get I got so baited there. Jesus Christ.
Oh, I got so [__] baited there.
Uh, okay. So, food shops quote tweets this. Sorry, I don't have
time to respond to allegations. I'm too busy crafting the runes
in Runescape. They will ground to dust later for selling telekinetic.
Okay, very cool. Huh? I don't have time to No, you're just a
You're just a uh He was saying that about Lauren. Oh, he's never
said that about Pixie. I could have I
I feel like he said that about Pixie. But hey, maybe he said
that about Lauren. I'm pretty confident he's called Pixie a who's
trying to sleep her way to the top multiple times. Like he's
actually Act actually I'm I'm almost positive you're totally
incorrect, Nick. But I you know that's my fault. I haven't been
covering that stuff on stream.
Yeah, he said everything I just said about Pixie. Yeah. Uh, you're
just totally wrong, Nick. Unfortunate. Okay. Anyway, what are
we getting to here? Food Chops quot tweets Ellie B Shimu in this
as well. We'll probably go over all the food chops replies if
nothing else. Okay. Food Chops did an entire stream talking about
how they have PCD obsessivempulsive disorder and how they use
to suppress it. Craziest attack on Twitch with this on I've ever
seen.
Yeah, this is
it's like all there.
It's all there for everybody to look through, man.
Ah, yeah. No, he did next. He He did multiple times now. I I
believe
um he's been going after like Supreme and Pixie together for
some reason. I think this somehow
somehow he thinks it helps him. I I really don't understand how
he thinks it helps him, but
hard to say, man. Food Chops gets an AI summary. Oh, I saw this
as well.
Whoa. Whoa. Hassan [__] calls food shops a in live
stream Clash. Food Chops a transgender woman who who clips streams
from creators like [__] reported the remark to Twitch
as a transphobic insult. Though the clip shows [__]
referencing her edgy statements without mentioning her gender.
Critics resurfaced Food Shop's own clips where she jokes about
preferring a 12-year-old in spooning, defends as unchangeable,
and calls herself a lowercase P while claiming no legal issues.
The exchange drew widespread mockery online with many backing
Piker's call out based on her admissions while a few criticized
his frequent use of the term.
Oh, so she literally even Grock's against you, bro. Even Even
Grock's against you, bruh.
Why would she post this? I don't know. I don't know. What is
she doing? Andrew Wilson coming to food shop's defense.
Really? No shot. Wait, no shot. No shot. That's true. Hold on.
No shot that's true. There's no way, Kilo, that's not true. Why
did you say that? Are you joking about something?
Are you joking about something? Oh, apparently this is about
Epstein.
Epstein and Trump. Hold on.
Uh, back in the Twitch politics debate days, the common tactic
of leftists would be to ped a person they didn't like. They knew
it would hurt him regardless of if it was true or not. Nothing
has changed on the national scale. This is the left's tactic
against
Maybe he got maybe he caught inspiration from this. I could see
how people think it's a a defense of food shops for sure, but
Andrew Wilson has debated food shops. I don't think he actually
believes I don't think Andrew Wilson actually believes
anything positive about her. Also, we could just go and look
at Andrew Wilson's debate with food shops cuz that was quite
funny. Hey, dumbass. There's a flatout statement of her admitting
it. Oh, this. And like clockwork, here's a leftist. He posted
a video of him opening a pickle jar.
Wait, that can't be. No, that's a Tik Tok. I thought that was
literally
>> I thought it was literally Ogre Boy, but there's there's
hair. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Never mind.
I thought it was Ogre Boy doing it himself. I'm pretty confident
he's not talking about food shops here in the first place cuz
I I I want to say
I want to say that Andrew has explicitly
I I feel like in that debate Andrew talked about them being or
something. Maybe I'm crazy. Maybe he didn't at all. Maybe he
didn't. Maybe he's just talking about how much of a spur they
were.
Anyway, that's funny. That is funny.
Whoa. You're a Whoa. Hold on. Tequila
>> Obviously because of that, right? And then I also admitted
I unironically consume. So if you don't like the fact that I
consume,
>> you're free to leave. Okay. >> Um, you know, >> wow.
know like that is just a part of me, you know, like it's it's
not like I can change my attractions or anything like that, right?
But I don't think >> I think um I think Andrew is maybe
he might have derived some like inspiration for this comment,
but I don't think he's meaning to defend food shops explicitly.
I just I can't see that. I really can't. Uh so food chops then
does this one,
which is a little weird. You follow Queenman who defends. You
have Kyle Written House in your community who's convicted woman
beater. You also have Jay- Sock who literally Cherry. I could
go on and on. Um
I think those last two are just objectively not true. But yeah,
sure. No real victims here at all, but opportunists and liars.
I Queman has defended Lolly a little bit in the past. Basically
saying that he doesn't think but last night he kind of said,
"No, I'm I'm going on the other side. I'm on the other side of
this now. You at least be ch a chill with daddy issue vibes or
with daddy vibes instead of a lame Whoa. Whoa. I didn't see where
that was going. Okay. All right.
I probably can't cover too much more of this. It seems like people
are getting a little little They're going hard in the uh in the
quote tweets there in the the replies.
We got a we got a reference to Dan. What is the reference to
Dan?
As we can see, as we can all see, the simple appearance of Dan
Saltman, by the way, is enough to prove his point, whatever that
means. Funny how Assan's biggest ops, except Destiny, are adjacent
to them. Assan's audience totally doesn't have an anti-semitism
problem.
Thanks for demonstrating my point. Oh, I see. So, somebody said,
you know, thanks for demonstrating my point, and he points these
two people out. I mean, I think it's probably, you know, we could
look through the the turkey sausage guy. We could look through
his replies where he's like totally totally Islamophobic like
all the time. I think uh I do like that food chops is using Dan
as a defense now. Dan's as a defense. Dan being being the guy
to prop up food shops. You love to see it.
You'd love to see it. Okay. I've got the substance suite. Where
is that at? Right here. Okay. Son the Hun responds to not food
shops calling for his ban for calling her a pedto. You have little
videos of you admitting to being a PDF file on the same platform
you're trying to get me banned off of. also sounds like Destiny
2, which is another one of the telltale signs. >> This
one is trying to get me banned off off Twitch, but you can't
you can't literally be like I'm transgender and that's why you're
calling me a >> When you have literal videos of you
I literally I actually do sweep for BPF quite often on this one.
I'm not His hand was not moving. It's He had traction. It wasn't
that he couldn't grip. It was that he couldn't torque. Okay,
I'm actually not sweeping this time. It's the opposite. >> Literally
be like, I'm transgender and that's why you're calling me a
when you have literal videos of you admitting to being a
on the same platform that you're trying to get me banned off
of. >> Oh, like you're like
big spoon is what you're saying.
Oh, I get [__] >> I need to have like a 12-year-old.
why? Why would she do this? Why did she do this? Why did she
do this? Why Why the would she do this? I don't get it. By the
way, I just want to point out that this was pointed out to Destiny
and others a long time ago. Destiny still goes on her stream
all the time, right? Destiny still wants to be totally tied to
this person, obviously. So, right. Destiny was just on her stream,
what, a week ago or something? Two weeks ago.
I'm pretty sure he goes on that stream all the time. Like what
do you mean? I I don't understand.
Yeah, I saw the dead domain one. Here's you admitting on camera
being attracted to children. >> But while I was like actually
covering the topic itself, right? Um >> they all Yeah,
they all know about it. You can't be like upset now, right? You
can't go, "Oh my god, Hassan's so disingenuous. We were pointing
this out for a long time."
>> I feel okay. She also is she sounds like Destiny too,
which is another one of the telltale signs. Like I don't understand
how the did this I don't understand how this community
uh was was designed around this this interest, but it is what
it is, I guess. >> So if you don't like the fact that I
you're free to leave. Okay.
um you know it like that is just a part of me you know like it's
it's not like I can change my attractions or anything like that
right but I don't think I'm a I really I thought she only consumed
because of the PCD thing
that's like another is that not another weird like derivation
a weird like change up I thought it was it was prescribed it
was prescribed no now it's just like I am a and you can't change
that about me Um,
dude, dude, dude. Yeah, but she was just lying when she said
that, I guess. So, I guess, I guess so.
God, do I have my I might have my old docket where I went through
all of this stuff. She changes it every time she speaks on it.
She really should have written this down at some point and decided
the direction she was going to go because she does just keep
switching up the story over and over and over again. And every
time you like miss a detail and something up and get things totally
wrong all over the place. Every time you do that, it looks worse
and worse and worse for you, right? It just consistently gets
worse and worse and worse. Yeah, it it's bad, man. It's bad.
Okay. All right. We had the Hassan response. What else we got
here? What else we got? Looking looking.
I will just be your pig pig.
Reban Rubin donated $3. She was prescribed Tyl Tylolal. Tyl.
Okay. Okay. All right. I I can see where you're going with that
one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right. All right.
Tyler Lol 12s. Okay. Tyler Lol 12s. You've heard of Tylenol 3?
Wait until you hear about Tyl 12s.
Make sure to like the tweet. Oh, sure, sure, sure. I'll uh I'll
>> This one is trying to get me banned. >> I'll retweet
right now on the stream. and we'll like it right now. >> You
can't speaking of pedal ops, this one was also going after you.
Yeah, I saw this earlier. Um, this one is trying to get me banned
off off Twitch, but you can't you can't literally be like, I'm
transgender and that's why you're calling me a when you have
literal videos of you admitting to being a
on the same platform that you're trying to get me banned off
of. Like, hey DJ, >> I will say the clip that he's talking
about that Han is talking about is a resi clip and resi was on
Twitch. >> The rest of my life. Keep Twitch a safe >> I've
got the food to defend Pedilia's nasty work. >> I'm only
into the most feminine of the most feminine. >> That's
what I'm saying. >> I need to I need to have a little girl
to wrap myself around. >> Oh, like your like big spoon
is what you're saying. Oh, I get [__] >> I
need to have like a 12-year-old. >> Hold on, hold on, hold
on. I will point out that Hassan didn't do any soundboard
at the I need a little girl to wrap myself around. He didn't
do any soundboard which means he knows that there's a worse statement
coming which means he's aware of this clip. Okay, just a little
investigation on Hassan there. He's obviously aware of the clip
cuz he knows there's something worse coming. Okay. >> Oh,
like you're like big spoon is what you're saying. Oh, I get you.
>> I need to have like a 12-year-old. What?
>> Like what do you mean? I don't
Um, someone I saw a tweet I thought it was funny. Doesn't he
keep sending like
uh HE REFERENCES THE DEEPER TWEET? LET'S GO. Let's go. >> Like
u Yeah, I saw the dead domain one. Here's you admitting on camera
being attracted to children. >> That's that's totally the
deeper tweet. >> But while I was
topic itself, right? Um Okay. But I need to say PD cuz I don't
think YouTube likes it. I don't think YouTube likes it when I
say say that. Okay. It's fake background. I got you. Yeah, I
figured it out. She also is she sounds like Destiny too, which
is another one of the telltale signs. Like I don't understand
how the [__] did this I don't understand how this
community
uh was was designed around this this interest, but it is what
it is, I guess. But yeah, someone said someone said Destiny keeps
sending different Destiny >> Oh, don't worry. I've got
the I've got the food chops comment. We're going to we're going
to fire it up. Don't worry. >> Sending different pedophiles
after a song like a Sailor Moon villain. >> So, obviously
that way. Then I also admitted at some point that unironically
>> uh the Deeperama tweet. The Deeperama tweet. Let's go.
Let's
go. Okay. It's so over for food shops, too. Food shops, dude.
Ah, everybody's winning. This is what I think this is what Trump
meant when Trump talked about like winning so much you're going
to get tired of winning. YOU'RE GOING TO SAY, "PLEASE STOP. PLEASE
STOP WINNING. PLEASE, I WANT TO STOP WINNING. PLEASE STOP LETTING
THEM WIN. PLEASE stop winning. It's too much. Too much winning.
That's what this is right now. It's just too much winning. Please
stop. Can we just win a little bit less? It hurts. It >> So,
if you don't like the fact that I that I unironically consume
less. So, if you don't like the fact that I consume, you're free
to leave. Okay. Um, you know, like that is just a part of me.
You know, like it's it's not like I can change. We're going to
win so much. YOU'RE GOING TO GET TIRED OF WINNING. YOU'RE GOING
TO SAY, "PLEASE, MR. TRUMP, STOP WINNING." BUT WE CAN'T STOP.
WE'RE JUST going to keep winning and winning and winning >> attractions
or anything like that, right? But I don't think I'm a I really
don't think so. >> Yeah. Destiny Orbiter 2 if you can believe
such a thing. Weird how it's always the exact people you expect.
Yeah. Why state this? Like what's the purpose? Dude, I don't
know, man. I don't know. I don't understand it. This was the
Hang on. So, is that person saying that people are coming after
her because she's trans? That's why they're saying is bad. No,
she tried to do the [__] woke uh she tried to She
tweeted this out of nowhere this morning. Hey, Twitch support.
Here's Assan Dhan blatantly calling me a transgender woman. I'm
pretty sure this is against Twitch to the leverage transphobic.
The funniest thing about this is like, you know who hates this
tweet most? It's not Hassan. It's not anybody but like Destiny
and Dan. Like she injected herself in a way that put her all
like starkly on Destiny's side, pointed to her her ties to these
people and basically tried to use trans like her transess as
a shield. It's like the worst possible tweet she could have done
for all of the people who are trying to get Hassan deplatformed
too. This is like the absolute worst thing that could have happened.
It's so funny, man. >> Insults against me. Clearly Hassan
is transphobic and he is no ally to trans people in any way.
The reason why she did that was because she's one of like Destiny's
new soldiers. She's one of Destiny's new soldiers and and I was
covering her briefly
uh in this in this saga with Stale 3000 or whatever the his name
is because
>> um Stale was in her chat being like, "Hey, I want to
turn you into a content creator off of LSF. I want to make you
famous on LSF." >> I think I think Stale has seen the light.
Okay, I think the light stale was unaware. Stale was unaware
because all of his old orbiters have actually left. Like all
of his old orbiters left. We need new orbiters. >> Uh,
notice Destiny not defending her or using the situation to attack
us on.
I I think he's going to have to come out and defend in some way.
It's We're going to get some Analike logs here. Okay, we're going
to whenever whenever Food Shops does eventually turn on Destiny
and leaks like the logs from this week, they're going to be analike.
Like, just listen. I'm just going to rub your feet. I'll I'll
clear up the allegations that you're later. Okay? I'm just going
to rub your feet right now. Just just chill. We're going to we're
just going to chill. Okay? I know. I know it's not true, but
I can't defend you right now, so I'll defend you later.
That's what's going to I I'm telling you, man. Those are the
DMs right now. >> None of them are actually cuz the whole
like Seam saga with Destiny uh caused a fissure in his community.
Like a lot of the people that were his friends, a lot of content
creators that were his friends realized that he's a piece of
[__] I don't know why it took so long, but they did.
And they started attacking him. And so he was like in the market
for new villains, I guess, like new loyal soldiers. and Stale
3000, the the Redditor mod of the year, the moderator of LSF.
Did you even know they were trans? Cuz I didn't. Yeah, I I don't
>> Do we have to pull out Do we have to pull out our Oh,
hold on. >> I didn't know until this very moment. Like
I just, you know, I don't assume things like that, but um
regardless regardless, what's crazy is um in the process of covering
that I was talking about how like, you know, this person has
like allegations, right? And then someone in my chat said, "No,
not outed. They admitted it. It turn >> We will have to
just in case we do more food shops content after this. Okay,
we do need our Valor Media Network seal of approval. Okay. For
a little bit later >> ops that I don't even know exist
out there. But this person claims they are lowercase P like serious
semantic brain.
>> Yeah, I think uh I think her thing is like she's um
>> I think I don't know precisely exactly everything. I
think it's something like I think I've I've read something a
little bit like >> but doesn't act on the desires or something.
I don't [__] Anyway, but basically, yeah, she was
like, "Oh, he's calling me a She's trying to get me banned."
Uh, working off of the uh working off of like the previous saga.
Anytime there's like controversy around me, like guys like this
will come out and will of course run the gamut.
getting called transphobic more than I am. Why is everyone nowadays
mandly calling me a transgender woman a >> I forget what
they're now. I do I do think Azenold here.
I I don't remember what he said precisely because I do remember
he did a video. I can't remember if he just called the person
gross or what >> called I think. No, it wasn't Lerox. Loner
box didn't work. Uh Hutch didn't work. They tried to like promote
Hutch a lot. They try to promote Loner Box a >> It's crazy.
Hassan's getting called transphobic nowadays more than I am.
I mean shift >> food shops. Uh you left out details. She
>> Yeah, this makes videos about me, too. >> Why
is everybody nowadays a to Hassan?
I wonder why I wonder why Asmin Gold constantly finds himself
defending people who are self-admitted.
H this one. Well, she says it out loud.
I forgot. Um there's also that as well. Apparently, this person
>> Everybody is like >> Yeah. So, it didn't really
work. It didn't really work. It didn't uh have to What are you
talking about? >> Well, it I like that he will just watch
like a clip like this and we'll just not investigate it at all.
Dude, Hassan, sorry. Asigold's got to see as this goes further.
I can't remember. Did Hassan want what is he talking about? That's
enough. That's the commentary from him. What these new moderator
is giving cops in a special in chat a special badge seriousness
democratic community by the way. What is this? Stop sending me
irrelevant [__] right now about brace. You are mocking.
What is this? Tune into clu kaizen clip didn't have any traction.
He is amplifying it so you get banned. Yeah, it's not going to
work though, especially because like when you have personally
admitted that first of all, like automatically.
Um, would you go on his turn to talk about any of this or Fentes?
Um, I don't know. I don't I have no idea.
I don't think like realistically
maybe only in that it would be like super beneficial for me to
go and like talk to him and his audience. like it probably couldn't
possibly hurt,
but like I don't I don't necessarily feel like um like that would
be smart for him. Maybe something changes. I don't know.
>> This person being like >> like I would do it.
I just don't think it would be smart for him. So I I don't like
expect it. You know what I'm >> I'm trans and he's calling
me a because I'm trans is ridiculous.
>> Sorry. The answer if you couldn't read between the lines
there. Obviously yes would be the answer, but it's like I don't
expect it. >> Okay. Secondly, the reason why I said that
is because you've admitted it. So, you can keep adding Dan Clansancy.
This is dangerous to my life. Keeping Twitch a safe platform
should be your highest priority. I've been docked before, too,
so his rabbid audience could go after me for this, too. No. Tagging
Twitch, too, just in case. Uh, his editors like Austinox has
to put Cobraate and Dr. Dre as comparable examples to me. Insane.
You basically call me a second, which is additionally insane
considering how I haven't been charged, arrested or had any contact
with FBI police whatsoever. I would like to see proof of this.
Why did she follow you? Because she's one of Destiny's insane
stalkers. Yeah, I like that her argument is I haven't been caught
thus far. So, you know, AI review and Twitter cooked her and
she reposted >> Okay. All right. All right. All right.
We've got all of this stuff. Now, food jobs has replied to the
Hassan tweet and she's replied. I think she's probably going
to do a stream on this as well. So, that'll be very funny to
watch a little bit later. It will be. So, this is uh we had the
Hassan response from Substance and now we've got here Kami Clicker
Hassan the Hun couldn't even get his facts right. Admitting it
on the same platform, admitting it on the same platform. The
vast majority of it, not all, happened on YouTube almost 3 years
ago. I'm almost positive Resi would have been on Twitch for this
and these are resi clips, but uh why not? I guess maybe she was
only on YouTube. Why not point towards an actual real credible
victim? Words and memes are is far a far less egregious crime
than just grifting your way through the Democratic party. Take
your journalism back to the brothel where you can r up more 16-year-old
chicks.
Dude, this the responses are so weak. That this is this is literally
you lick sn. Hey, Hassan [__] you lick snizz, bro.
Go find me her reaction to the you lick snizz clip from Andrew
Wilson because that's literally how she starts this out. You
lick snizz. You lick snizz, you stupid [__]
Exactly the same level of weakness. Exactly the same level of
just like totally cringe.
It's okay.
Okay. I I don't get it. So, she comes in and lies because Hassan
told the truth, I guess.
The By the way, the lie she points out also is not about her
being a Okay. The lie she points out is actually I admitted to
being a on YouTube, not Twitch. Huh. Actually, little bit of
misinfo on your part, Hassan. When I said I was a I actually
did that on YouTube and not Twitch. You're you're you're promoting
misinformation. You're actually promoting misinformation right
now. It's like, what the are you talking about? Are you Are you
serious?
Are you Are you serious? Yeah. Yeah, it is the same thing. I
never admitted to having a on Twitch. I'VE NEVER ONCE SAID I
was dragging little girls
on Twitch. It's like, "Hey, bro, can you can you just be for
real for two seconds?
Are you serious right now? Is this a real thing?" Uh, so food
drops is still going in on Had apparently. I wonder how many
girls that sent Hassan the Hun nudes gave him consent to share
those uh share with his friends IRL. I wonder how many of them
even verified their own age. Hm. Makes you think Hassan's distribution
arc, but yeah, sure. Let's keep focusing on and edgy memes. Why
not? Well, I think the issue here would be that people were sending
him stuff on Snapchat, right? That he didn't know,
right? That he like I I do think this is just obviously weak.
I gave this advice to them during the whole uh Oh, it was like
right at the beginning. Dan tried to pull this up as like, oh,
Hassan's basically the same as as Destiny. It's like, bro, like
he didn't consent to having those dudes sent to him. That's not
him consenting to that thing, right? It's way different. It's
like an entirely different category of things.
Okay. Okay.
It's It's just It's very goofy, but this this the best they can
do. This the best they can do, I suppose. Unlucky, man. Now,
we went from the Asmin Gold thing. Do we want to watch the Asmin
Gold video that he did on food shops?
We have to mix in the Chibi Review stuff as well.
Okay, let's do the Chibi Reviews review really quickly. Are we
done with this? We're basically done with this. We could maybe
listen a little bit more here real quick. representing her age
by making a gender pick which own clips where she jokes about
preferring a 12-year-old in spooning defense lolly Kong's lolly
Kong is unchangeable and calls herself lowercase Pedophile while
claiming no legal issues oh my god loll manifesto too okay maybe
we could do the manifesto [__] I didn't realize we're
going to do content tonight like this I was here to play World
of Warcraft
okay fine that's where when the content comes out to follow it
okay her ass
mockery online with many backing pigers call out based on our
admissions while a few critics criticizes frequent use of the
term. But yeah,
Asmin Gold of course highlighting the clip, hoping that it actually
gets traction is is once again finding himself defending yet
another, you know, selfdeclared self-admitted enjoyer out. I
there dude, there's no way as there's not more to the Asen Gold
stream here where he like keeps watching and he gets like a clip
or something and he goes, "Oh, never mind. That that person's
weird, right?" For sure. For sure. Tonight we had to have Asmin
Gold. Oh, come on. You got to unblock throwaway. Nicholas Dioro
and
Hassan. Unblock throwaway. Unleash throwaway. Unblock throwaway.
Okay. If you guys aren't going to If Assan doesn't have Oband,
he should blocked. He shouldn't have throwaway blocked. Okay.
>> Unblock throwaway. Got to unblock them. There are ops
that I don't even know exist out there, but one thing is a guarantee.
They are going to be criminals in some variety, some way, shape,
or form. Um, this is like the the primary driving force behind
almost all of my ops. Everybody hates you because they're like
freaks. Okay.
>> Yeah. I mean, look, I don't I don't think so. I didn't
think so. Okay. I didn't think so. This just how didn't Hassan
an underage girl at a brothel? No. And that's not even the allegation
that people make who've ever looked into it even make against
him.
So, so no to start with and then that's not even you are misunderstanding
what the actual allegation could be. And the actual allegations
like way
I from what I understand the actual allegation that they would
make is like he went to a brothel that had traffic kids but then
there's not even necessarily proof that the brothel had anything
to do with tracking kids. >> How it keeps unfolding you
know there's a if you exist for a long enough timeline and you're
an op of mine you end up getting into trouble in this way somehow.
I don't know why but in any case I forget what >> man that's
weird and >> why has this is crazy. This goes insane. We
really doing mass ducks. We are 36 hours away from another Elon
Grock tweaking and Grock generating more CM than all of four
chance history. I don't know why Asmin Gold keeps defending these
people, but how can he? Turns out that you don't need to be friends
with Asmo for him to defend their fest. I >> it's kind
of crazy
that he is like, you
>> this one apparently this person had made videos about
Asmin Gold too and he's >> Why are we watching Hassan?
He is disgusting. Uh no, he's actually winning now. Unfortunately,
you know, while we don't agree with his politics, when Hassan
covers drama right now, he's actually just totally winning.
The only reason you'd find him disgusting is, you know, if you
shared some of the proclivities of the people he's criticizing.
Is that what's is that what's happening here? Hold on. Hold on.
Oh, do I have to do this to you? I don't want to have to do this
to you. I just Rory, I'm so sorry I have to do it to you. Okay.
I'm so sorry, but I just pulled up your Twitch profile. Okay,
that's the profile character.
THIS IS COME ON, MAN. COME ON, DUDE. COME ON, DUDE. Come on,
man. Come on. Come on, man.
I This is absolutely disgusting. He's saying like are danger
to society in some way. It's totally disgusting. It's every time.
Every time. Every time. Still defending her. So, at that point,
I assume there's a second reason. Is it because like they're
a selfidentifying Is that what it is? Is that what happened?
Cuz that video itself,
that video itself was me addressing how so many of my haters
end up, >> doesn't this community hate Hassan? Well, this
community used to hate Hassan. We've had a lot of churn over
the Hassan is bad question. Some people stayed. Some people were
like, okay, Hassan's not evil. Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad sometimes.
Okay,
but we've had a lot of churn over the over the
months here. Okay. So, the community is a little more ambivalent
or even possibly in some cases liking Hassan now. Okay. It's
a very different community than it was a few months ago.
Yeah, there are still some people who dislike Hassan. And like
if if you want to point out some of his politics that are bad,
I usually would agree with you, right? But we usually cover drama
here. And on the drama stuff, at least the people going after
Hassan,
they tend to be way worse people. Like every time. It's actually
crazy how often it happens. And really, we're watching food shops
try to play this out in real time, right? She is trying to Hassan
is bad out of the stuff.
She's literally gonna go through how bad Hassan is to try to
get out of the
Like, we're watching it happen again. I can't tell you how funny
it is that you point this out and people get so mad that they
force themselves to do it again and again and again and again.
They just keep redoubling down on Hassan is bad to get out of
whatever allegations are against them. Aan is bad. Assan is bad.
Okay. All right. Okay. Yeah. Food shop started this for no reason.
So, we're okay with animal abuse. I actually said from the very
beginning one nerf, like when I probably had a more negative
opinion of that, that even with the shot caller, I didn't think
it was animal abuse. The really the real criticism you should
have is not that it could possibly be animal abuse because I
don't think it even arguably is. It would be that he lied, right?
That he lied about it being animal or lied about there being
a shot caller. It would be about him lying. You don't even have
like the right the right condemnation.
If you're arguing that it's animal abuse, I think you're out
of your mind personally. The dog's very well taken care of.
>> Uh so many of my haters end up getting outed as like
criminals or you know what I mean. So Asmin Gold defended Chibi
Reviews and then ended up defending uh the this this ped >> wait
as there's no way Asminold defended Chibi Reviews. There's no
possible way that Asmin Gold defended Chibi Reviews. It's a hot
take that that like correction callers like e-collars are not
abuse. That's a hot take. I don't think that's a hot take at
all. Asmin Gold is Chiby's friend. I don't believe you. I don't
believe you. I don't believe you. Well, hold on. Defending Chibi.
Wait, no. Maybe I do believe you. The Chibi stuff, the Chibi
stuff to other people looks very different. You need to be very
aware of who Chibi is and who he's been over months and months
and months to understand why this is funny. If you just look
at it on its face, it's like this guy's wife cheated on him with
his best friend and everybody's laughing and mocking him. If
you just see that part, I do see how you could actually show
up and defend Chibi. If you're unaware, I do get it. That does
make a little more sense to me, right? I get it cuz I watched
it happen on um the Riyle channel when it's looks like I'm just
laughing at this guy who got cheated on. I People get very mad
about that. Okay. How did you dodge the anti pedtoora back in
your Hassan Alog days? Uh by not being a by not Yeah. Boom. Easy.
>> Shops.
There's other better reviews and ped shops.